[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIRILL TROPIN: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for coming in.
My name is Kirill Tropin.
I'm product manager on Google
Cloud Storage and today
we'll talk about selecting
the right storage
class for your
workload or whatever
it might be, either content
storage and delivery, big data
analytics, or long tail
content that you may not
be using as much.
I'll have quite a few
speakers joining me on stage
later on in this presentation.
I'll introduce them as we go.
But let's start with Google
Cloud Storage overall.
So GCS, or Google Cloud Storage,
is highly available, durable,
and simple object storage.
We see a lot of success in
GCS across different storage
classes, big data analytics,
content storage and delivery,
and cold storage as well.
And GCS is built in exactly
the same infrastructure
as we use internally at Google
for different objects storage.
And chances are, if
you have not used GCS
before, probably you've used
exactly the same technology
for any other Google products.
And, as I said, exactly
same infrastructures,
exactly the same engineers
maintaining and building
that infrastructure, same data
centers, same disk, same racks,
and same network.
So we see quite a lot of
success across those scenarios.
And let me walk you
through couple examples how
customers are using GCS today.
So starting from left to
right, with content storage
and delivery, we see
quite a few customers
using GCS for serving video,
serving music, serving images,
serving any general multimedia
or just serving websites
and static content through GCS.
Then on big data side, if
you have a lot of data,
If you have petabyte scale,
hundred petabyte scale,
or even exabyte scale, you need
to keep your data somewhere.
And GCS is the place to
keep your exabyte scale data
and then run compute
jobs on top of that.
So I have quite a
few customers who
run big data analytics that run
their custom pipelines, custom
workloads.
They do different
genomics processing,
different e-commerce analytics,
IoT, different manufacturing
modeling, and you see quite
a few of those examples here.
And then, if you look at
those customers, many of them
have hot data and
working data sets
that they are
processing regularly,
but then they also
have some data
that they want to archive
or backup for long term.
And pretty much
every single customer
will have some sort of
infrequently accessed data
or some sort of cold data.
Other than that, we
also have customers
that use GCS purely
for storing cold data
and long-term archive.
We also have quite
a few partners
that use GCS to help
ingest data from on-prem
or help archive different
enterprise data in GCS.
So GCS today has four
main storage classes
and I'll look in detail
across all of them
throughout this presentation.
So starting from left
to right, so left,
the hardest one is
Multi-regional storage.
It's built for
storage and delivery.
It's geo redundant so
it's perfect for business
continuating.
If a single region
in GCS goes down
or something happens
to that region,
you don't need to
worry about it.
We'll keep serving your
requests because your data
is geo redundant across
two or more regions
within a multi-regional
location.
And we see customers use that
storage for streaming videos,
serving images and website
content and documents.
Second class is
regional storage class.
It's built for data analytics
within a single region.
If you are running some
computer workloads,
you want to have your
data stored right next
to your computer workloads.
You want to have lowest
latency possible,
high throughput possible,
and regional storage class
is the right place
for storing data
for different analytics
workloads or general computer
workloads.
And both of those storage
classes are built for hard data
and they provide highest
level of availability
across our four storage classes.
Then moving to the
right, you will
see two storage classes that
are built for cold or cool data.
So that's Nearline, which
is built for data access
less than once a month.
And then its Coldline data
that's accessed less than once
a year on average.
And we see customers use
those storage classes
for serving long tail content
or for disaster recovery
or for archive.
Beautiful part about
those two storage classes
is they have exactly the
same API as any other storage
class in GCS.
So it's very easy for you to
integrate with those storage
classes.
Once you start using GCS, either
it's hot data or cold data,
you can use any
other storage class
because its exactly
the same API.
And for all of our
storage classes,
we provide online latency.
So that means you
don't need to engineer
around data
retrievals or anything
like that, because
all of the latency
is consistent across
storage classes.
So let's go into detail into
content storage and delivery.
I'll start with our
Multi-regional storage.
And then I'll invite product
manager from Firebase
to talk more about
Firebase and how
it's helpful for content
storage and delivery.
So our Multi-regional storage
is best for content serving.
As I said before, it's geo
redundant across two or more
regions.
And we provide very simple
API and very simple pricing.
So it's exactly the same
API as for regional storage.
Just provide location name, in
this case it's US, EU, or Asia.
And then you create a bucket
and start uploading data.
You don't need to worry about
your primary or secondary
regions, we'll take
care of all of that.
It's a very simple API to use.
And because data
is geo redundant,
we'll take care of
different failovers.
And it's very good for
your business continuity
as well, because you
don't need to worry
about some region going
down inside of GCS.
So as I said, we have three
Multi-regional locations today.
So we have a lot of different
regions in Google Cloud
platform.
And we're building, pretty
much a new region every month
or every two months.
So right now, we have three
Multi-regional locations
that unite multiple
regions inside of them.
So one of them is US,
the other one is EU,
and third one is Asia.
And customers that
want to serve content
either within those locations
or around the world,
they could use one of
those storage locations.
So let me talk a little bit
more about that simple API
for Multi-regional
storage classes.
So here's an example of creating
a Multi-regional storage
class with a common line
utilities called gsutil.
And I provide a type of storage
class, which is Multi-regional.
I provide location, US.
And then I just name my bucket.
Literally, there is nothing
else you need to provide.
We'll take care of
everything else.
We'll take care of where
to store your data,
and you don't need
to worry about it.
And when you retrieve
your data, again, you
don't need to specify
any locations.
Just provide your bucket
name, domain name, and then
the name of your file.
That's it.
You don't need to
worry about routing.
We'll take care of routing
within our network.
You don't need to worry if
it's east, west, Europe, US.
We'll take care of all of that
routing on our Google network.
Multi-regional storage
class is also optimized
for end user latency, because
there are multiple layers
of caching that we have in GCS.
So even though you might be
storing data in Multi-regional
US, if you have customers
that are accessing
the data from Europe, we'll
cache the data in Europe
in our data centers.
Similarly, in Asia Pacific,
we'll cache in our data centers
in Asia Pacific.
And on top of that, if you
set your objects to be public,
we'll also cache those
objects at the edge
in our points of presence.
We have around 100 points of
presence around the world.
And we'll leverage the
same infrastructure
as for other internal
Google products
or, for instance, YouTube.
And we'll cache the data in
those points of presence.
So your consumers in large
cities around the world
will have extremely low latency,
because data will actually
be served from location right
next to them in that city.
In terms of price,
we charge very simple
2.6 cents per gigabyte
month for your data
in Multi-regional storage class.
And we'll take care of all
their applications underneath.
You don't need to worry about
paying for network to replicate
your data across data centers.
You don't need to worry about
secondary copy or tertiary
copy.
Everything is included
in that simple 2.6
cents per gigabyte month price.
We'll also charge
for read operations
and write operations.
And we've recently decreased
the price by 50% and 60%.
We decreased it half a year ago.
And we have very
competitive price on storage
and the operations there.
In terms of availability,
typically, the storage class
runs at four 9's
availability, and we
provide 3 and 1/2 9's SLA.
So if for some reason
it drops, within a given
month below 3 and 1/2
9's, we'll pay you back
for using that storage
class depending
on how available it was.
And it's also designed
for 11 9's durability.
All of our storage
classes are durable.
So you don't need to worry
about some storage class
being less durable
than the other.
We provide the same standard
durability across all of them.
Turns out, a lot
of data is actually
being consumed on mobile phones.
So it's extremely
important for our customers
to be able to build applications
and be able to serve the data
and consume the data
from a mobile phone.
So I'd like to invite Mike
McDonald, who is the Project
Manager on Firebase, to talk
about using Google Cloud
Storage with Firebase APA.
MIKE MCDONALD: Thanks, Kirill.
How is everyone doing today?
Good?
Awesome.
How many of you have
heard of Firebase?
Couple people.
How many of you
operate mobile apps?
Hopefully, oh come on, you
guys the world is mobile first.
So what Firebase is,
oh I have a clicker.
Firebase is Google's
mobile platform.
So Firebase allows you to
develop your applications
on Google Cloud Platform, grow
your user base using our--
we have push
notifications, we have
application invites, all
of that kind of stuff.
And we also have a
monetization platform.
So you can earn more money by
integrating with our products.
But for those of
you who are building
mobile apps, how many
of your mobile apps
are serving some
kind of rich content?
So you're serving media, you're
serving images or videos.
All of that, you need to
be able to easily upload
from the user's mobile
device and then transmit
those around the world.
Firebase offers really great
mobile support for Google Cloud
Storage through our SDKs.
And those SDKs--
I'm going to go to
the next slide--
are optimized for
mobile content delivery.
So we handle tricky problems
like really granular security.
So if you want your users
to sign-in via Facebook
and upload a photo,
we can integrate
with Firebase
authentication, which
does server list sign-on to
Facebook and then lets you,
again, without a server, upload
directly from your device
to Google Cloud Storage, to any
Google Cloud Storage bucket.
We also do that on the clients.
We have very robust networking.
So how many of you guys are
enjoying the conference Wi-Fi?
Things are pretty slow.
Are you trying to send tweets
and take pictures and share
them with people?
Have you had any uploads fail?
It's because people
aren't doing it robustly.
So our networks our SDKs are
going to do resumable uploads.
And I'll actually show
that, because I've
been having fun doing my demo
earlier over this network.
And so we're going to make sure
that your uploads and downloads
get to where they need to
go even if the network is
terrible.
And as Krill has
been talking about,
it's all built for Google scale.
So we support five
terabyte uploads direct
from your mobile phone.
And I actually have a standing
thing, you can tweet at me.
If someone ever finds out
how to upload five terabytes
from a mobile phone, let me know
because I have a job for you.
So let's switch over to the
demo, because listening to me
talk about this is
really not exciting.
How many people have
programmed an iOS app?
Or does SWIFT code look
at all familiar to people?
Maybe?
Hopefully it's not too crazy.
I have over here an iPhone app.
And it's going to look really
boring when I start it up
because there's
nothing going on.
But if you click that
little camera button,
it's going to take us
over to a photo picker.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to take a picture from
the phone, upload Google Cloud
Storage, and then download
it again to the device.
So we're going to do
that all with Firebase.
So this is actually about 100
lines of code just as a shell.
But, yes this works.
We are going to--
and ah-ha, I didn't
delete my sample.
There we go.
We're going to first
upload the image.
So we're going to create a
reference to our Cloud storage
bucket.
And then, we are going
to upload our image just
using this PUT method.
And so that takes the
image that we clicked,
and it's going to upload
that Google Cloud Storage.
We'll also add an observer
to let us know the progress,
because I was noticing earlier
today it was pretty slow.
So what this is going
to do is it's just
going to print out
and let us know
how quickly things are going.
So I will rerun that.
And to prove to you that
this is going to work,
the app will open up over here.
We will select a photo.
By the way, the
Apple System Photos
are about 20 megs in size.
They're pretty big.
Oh, and there we go.
Actually, the internet
was pretty quick.
So you can see that we
fully uploaded our file.
Let's pop over to the Firebase
console and refresh the page.
And we can go ahead
and see, we now
have a folder that says
"Photos" and we even
have the photo in there.
That was like one line of
code that uploaded a photo.
No?
No clapping?
OK.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Small applause, that's--
we're not done yet.
So now we're going
to synchronize that.
So we're actually using
another Firebase product.
It's our Realtime Database.
And we've already written
that data, basically
the sharable URL for that
location in Cloud Storage.
And now, we're going to download
that image and display it.
So all you need to
do there is, you
can take that URL that we
synchronized via our database
and just say, get the data.
And they're about 20
megs, so I'm making sure
that we have enough.
And then we simply put
it in our app and reload.
We'll go ahead and
start that back up.
And the nice thing,
actually, about the database
is it's going to immediately
take the first photo that I
uploaded last, and it's
downloading it right now.
And there it is.
So that was actually
pretty quick.
But because I like
to live dangerously,
and because I'm a Millennial,
I have another version
of the app on my phone.
And I'm going to take a
selfie with all of you.
And let's see how
long this takes.
So it's uploading right now.
And there we go.
Oh, I'm upside down.
Sorry about that.
But there you go.
So that was maybe
10 lines of code,
including all of the
application logic,
to upload and download
from Google Cloud
Storage on an iPhone app.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And back to Kirill.
KIRILL TROPIN: Thank you, Mike.
So all of that is still backed
by Google Cloud Storage.
So that means, when you
are leveraging Firebase,
all of the data will be
transferred by Google Cloud
Storage--
will be stored on
Google Cloud Storage
and transferred
by Google Network.
So it will be amazingly fast.
And it will scale to extremely
large applications that serving
that content around the world.
So let's go back to
big data analytics now.
So if you have a
lot of data, you
need a place to store it
before you analyze it.
And Google Cloud
Storage Regional Bucket
is the right place
to store the data.
So data with GCS Regional
is redundant within a given
region.
And if you select
Compute Engine and GCS
Regional in the
same region, you'll
get the lowest latency
possible between those two.
And it's built for
data access frequently.
So that means if you have
some application that
process that data lot this is
the best storage class to use.
Similarly to any
other storage class,
GCS is very deeply integrated
with other products
within Google Cloud
Platform, like Data Procmail,
Google Compute Engine,
Genomics, even BigQuery.
So you can potentially
store data in GCS
and query it directly out of
BigQuery, [INAUDIBLE] query.
And a lot of customers
use this storage class
to run different pipelines
and analyze their data
from either of their customer
plans and Google Compute Engine
or by our products.
And because it's
so well-integrated,
it's very easy to get started--
let's say, when you're
migrating from Hadoop on-prem,
migrating to Google
Cloud Platform.
So one of our products
in Google Cloud Platform
was Cloud DataProc.
And it's essentially a managed
Spark and Hadoop service.
And we have a Cloud
Storage connector,
which is HCFS compliant
as part of the product.
And that means it's
very easy for you
to move from Hadoop on-prem
to GCS and DataProc.
So here's the example at the
bottom of changing your code,
essentially just
changing one line.
It's how you're
referencing your storage.
And everything else, all the
other code will keep working.
And that Cloud Storage connector
will take care of everything.
And you don't need to change
any other lines of code.
And that solves a lot of
problems for customers.
Because data is
stored in GCS, you
don't need to worry about
scaling that data over time,
like you might need
to worry on-prem.
The data is also accessible
outside of your Hadoop
clusters.
You can turn it down, and
your data will still be there.
It's still in GCS.
You can turn up another
cluster and access the data.
So that provides a
lot of simplicity
and a lot of flexibility
for our customers.
If you want to read
more about DataProc,
you can go to
cloud.google.com/dataproc/.
Similarly to our
Multi-regional storage,
we charge a very simple price
of $0.02 per gigabyte month.
We charge also for operations.
And we provide three
9's availability SLA.
So as you see, our SLA for
regional storage class is
slightly lower than the
one from Multi-regional,
where we provide 3 and 1/2 9's.
And that's because
regional storage is not
geo redundant as
Multi-regional storage class.
And it also has
11 9's durability.
It has instant access,
like anything else in GCS.
And we have exactly the
same API that you would
use across all storage classes.
So once you start using
regional storage class,
you can easily switch to
using any other storage class.
But enough hearing from me.
I'd prefer to hear
from real customer.
So I'd like to invite Fastly,
our dear customer and partner,
and specifically, Artur
Bergman, their CEO.
ARTUR BERGMAN: Thank you.
Thank you.
This works?
All right.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Artur Bergman.
I'm CEO of Fastly.
And we are both, as
Kirill said, a customer
and a partner of Google.
So what we are is a edge cloud.
So in the old world, you had
a whole bunch of edge devices
in your own data center.
And as you're
moving to the cloud,
those old, expensive,
inflexible, unreliable hardware
machines that you had at
the edge of your data center
have no longer anywhere to live.
And so that's where we come in.
So we complement very well
together with central cloud,
so we integrated really
well with Google.
So we provide
caching, edge compute,
TLFS termination, load
balancing disability,
as a complement to the
storage and computing and et
cetera that you get
on the other side.
So how it works, we have
interconnections with Google
in quite a few locations
around the world
to the Google network.
And then we have our own POPs
all around the world, where
we store your content,
process your content,
defend your content
to end users,
whether those are humans,
or machines, or et cetera,
all around the world.
So could also, at some
point, be described as a CDN.
One of the really cool things
that we found with Google
is the cloud functions.
So one of the core
functionality we provide
is that you want the view
that the rest of the world
has of your content
to be up-to-date.
So we do cache
invalidation, or purging,
in about 150
milliseconds worldwide.
And so here's a very simple
cloud function for Google Cloud
Storage, so that when
you upload or change
an image or any piece of
data on Google Cloud Storage,
that cache invalidation
goes out worldwide.
And the new content is
available from any edge POP,
completely transparently.
So we really like working with
partners who are really, really
good and provide really good
performance, and service,
and reliability
to our customers.
Because at the end
of the day, we're
here to provide fantastic
reliability and performance
to our customers.
And if we bring in
partners or work
with partners who don't,
that causes problems.
And so I went and looked
at some performance metrics
that we're collecting
from Google Cloud Storage
versus Amazon S3.
And this is not
a synthetic test.
This is actually looking
at very, very large data
sets of content being
fetched from both.
And the difference
is pretty dramatic.
So the scale on the
lower is different,
but what you're seeing
there is a average Time
To First Byte of three
to five milliseconds
versus 200 milliseconds.
And so again, this is
two very large data sets,
where we're fetching cache
misses from S3 or Google Cloud
Storage.
And in both cases, it's
S3 East and GCS East,
which is one of the
reasons we really
love working with
Google, because this just
creates a better
experience for everyone--
both engineers, and our
customers, and their end users.
So at the use cases
we're looking at,
and we have some pretty
amazing customers together--
Spotify, Vimeo, and
Firebase was earlier--
obviously, our own caching,
caching closer to user.
But also in the big
data analytics side,
we integrate really well.
And from a security
point of view,
the real time aspects of the
platform and the integration
of Google allows you to do
some pretty amazing stuff.
So use cases are, in
this case, pretty simple,
especially like Vimeo, that's,
obviously, video and images.
Spotify is, as people can guess,
a tremendous amount of audio.
But there's a lot
of other cool things
that they do with us as well.
We also do real time
log files from the edge,
which is pretty key, because
as you're moving functionality
that you used to have in
your own sphere of control,
you need that--
when you had it in your own data
center and your own control,
you knew what was
going on in real time.
And you need that once you move
it out in the cloud as well.
And so we have
these real time logs
that update in about a second.
And we can stream those
into Google Cloud Storage
and then get that into BigQuery
in pretty much real time.
That's something we use
internally very much.
So seeing that two-way
integration just
creates a really nice
experience for engineers,
for developers, and operations.
So internally, we use
that a lot for analyzing
performance of GCP connections
between end users and us.
So we see on the order
of 3 or 4 million TCP
connections per second.
At any given time,
we'll have about 150,
200 million TCP
connections open.
And we want to know as
much data about these as
possible to detect problems
on the internet router, around
those problems, et cetera.
And what we ended up
using is BigQuery.
And we put in somewhere
between about 50,000
and 100,000 records per
second into BigQuery.
We also use it for
edge enforcement,
which I'll go into in a second.
And then we have customers
who use it in the AdTech space
or for Beacons that are
collecting data through Fastly.
And then, instead of having
to run their own data,
like their own servers,
to terminate that request
and put it into
Google Cloud Storage,
they're just having
Fastly dump it directly
into Cloud Storage, so
serverless, basically.
We use it for edge
threat analytics.
So we have a live product,
and we provide edge security
for our customers.
So we use GCS, and
BigQuery, and edge
logs for that and
basically, very quickly can
pull any kind of
report from the edge
to see what rules are
hitting, what kind of threats
we're seeing, anomaly
scores, et cetera.
And we can then expose
that to our customers.
So the total
pipeline of end user
fetching something from
us, we don't have it,
we fetch it from Google.
If we have it, we give
them, we process it,
we apply whatever rules and
logic around that we need to.
And then we log it into Google.
And then we use the Google
Tools for Analytics.
And so you can then integrate
that with whatever pipelines
you have for other kind of
analytics, for using Tableau
or something like that, or
one of the security packages.
It works really well.
And you can use the standard
Google Visualizations
that they have to just create
reports really, really fast.
So the combination really
lets you build a very, very
compelling replacement
to the old combination
of having your own storage and
then a boring CDN out there
that doesn't actually do what
you want to do on either side.
That combination, that
two-way integration
really allows you to
drive a lot of value.
And the value really
comes from two points.
One is the customer experience,
your end user experience.
But I think a very
important point is also
the internal engineering
and product experience.
So it allows your developers, it
allows your product engineers,
your product managers
to just move faster
and to get new
functionality out,
because all the APIs, all the
documentation, API functions,
modules, et cetera, are just
so accessible in real time.
You don't have to go through
this kind of painful process
that you traditionally
had to do to get all
these systems working together.
So you can just
release code faster,
keep your engineers happier,
and keep, by extension, your end
users faster.
So we're big fans of Google.
We use them internally.
We have very big
customers together.
And we would love to have more
of you using both us and Google
together.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
KIRILL TROPIN: Thank you, Artur.
So we've talked a lot about big
data analytics and the content
serving.
But all of those customers they
have some sort of cold data.
So over time, they
collect a lot of data.
And that data may not
be as commonly used
as it used to be when it
was just first generated.
And typically, customers will
want to save money on the data.
I'm sure everyone wants to save
money on their infrastructure.
And if the data is not
being used that often,
probably you want to
pay less for the data.
And so I will have
two storage classes
that are designed for
cool and cold data.
So one of them is Nearline.
Another one is Coldline.
I'll start with Nearline here.
So Nearline is a
storage class that
is designed for
infrequently accessed data.
It provides the same instant
access speed and the same API
as other storage classes.
And it's extremely
important for our customers.
So what that means, if you're
using Multi-regional storage
class for content
serving and delivery
and then, turns out
not all of your data
is frequently accessed and
you want to store some of it
in Nearline, well,
it turns out you can
use all of your integrations.
You can use our
partnership with Fastly
to serve the content
around the world
or you can use any
big data tools that we
have at Google Cloud Platform.
And you don't need
to change anything,
because it's exactly
the same API.
It's exactly the same latency.
You don't need to do anything
extra on top of that.
So some typical examples
include storing historical data
and then maybe analyzing
the data in the future.
So sometimes you don't know
how the data might end up being
useful for you in the future.
So you want to keep it
around and still probably
have low latency
and some chances
to access the data
in the future.
Customers also use Nearline
to serve long tail content.
So if you have a lot of
different multimedia content,
some of it will not be
as frequently accessed
as the other ones.
So you can put your cold content
or your long tail content
on Nearline.
So for Nearline,
we charge you $0.01
per gigabyte month on storage.
And we also charge for
access of $0.01 per gigabyte
of data right out of Nearline.
And if you recall those two
numbers and storage price
for Multi-regional
storage, turns out
that Nearline becomes
the cheapest storage
class for data that's accessed
less than once a month.
And that's where that
statement comes in
that Nearline is built
for data that is accessed
less than once a month.
For Nearline we provide SLA.
We provide two 9's SLA.
And it's consistent API
and consistent performance,
like with any other
storage classes.
So if you've been with
us for a couple of years
you might have seen
Nearline two years ago.
And back then, we had four
second latency on Nearline.
And we've been working
very hard and improving
performance and reliability of
Nearline and any other storage
class.
So over last year we've
increased availability SLA
on Multi-regional storage class
and also decreased latency
in Nearline all the
way from four seconds
all the way down to instant
access speed with Nearline.
And we are committed
to continuously improve
our performance and reliability
in Google Cloud Storage.
And those improvements
that we've
made with Nearline
last year, bringing it
all the way to
instant access speed,
allowed us to ship a new storage
class that's called Coldline.
We've launched it last October.
And Coldline is
best for cold data,
specifically data that's
accessed less than once a year
on average.
Similarly to Nearline, it has
all of the integration points
it has exactly the same API.
But because it's built
for very cold data,
customers usually use it
for archive or storing
multimedia source files.
So if you don't expect
to transcode your data,
that often you still want to
have your multimedia sources
somewhere and customers
choose Coldline
for that scenario and
also disaster recovery.
And that's a very important
point with disaster recovery.
In case something happens
to your core data set,
you want to be able to pull
the data out very quickly.
And usually customers cannot
use state media for this or any
sort of media that
has latency in it.
And with Coldline you
have instant access speed
so you can start accessing
the data right away.
And more than that,
because Coldline
has exactly the same API
as any other storage class,
you can start serving
directly out of Coldline,
or using the data that
your storing in Coldline
for processing right
away without any delay,
because API is exactly the same.
And customers find
it much more simpler
than any other solutions in
the market that they have.
They just switch the
traffic to different bucket,
and they start using it.
In terms of price,
we charge $0.07
per gigabyte month for Coldline.
And we also charge $0.05
per gigabyte on data access.
And that works out that, if your
data is accessed less than once
a year, Coldline becomes the
cheapest storage class for you
to use.
We also provide availability
SLA for Coldline.
We provide two lines
of availability
SLA, exactly the
same as Nearline.
And we also have minimal
storage duration for Coldline
at 90 days.
So let me show you a
little bit about that API
and that performance.
So people sometimes
don't believe me,
do you really have
exactly the same API?
Well, it's exactly the same.
Here's an example of doing
GET or HTTP PUT with Coldline.
And it's exactly the
same API as you've
seen a few slides back with
Multi-regional storage.
You provide name of your bucket.
In my case it was Coldline.
I was the one to claim Coldline
as the name of my bucket.
You provide your domain
name and then your file.
And that's it.
It's exactly the same
API as anywhere else.
In terms of performance,
here's an example
of reading one megabyte
out of Coldline.
So we have a utility
that's called gsutil,
Google Storage
Utility, and then run
perfdiag with that utility and
downloaded one megabyte file
from Coldline.
And as you can see here,
it's between 150 and 200
milliseconds to download
one megabyte file,
which is quite impressive.
Many customers cannot achieve
this with their other solutions
for hot data.
And we achieved this with
Coldline, less than 200
millisecond latency to pull
out one meg file out of coldest
tier that we have.
So we see a lot of
customers tiering that data
from hot storage
to cold storage.
But they can also tier
their storage from on-prem,
all the way to cloud, and
all the way to Coldline.
So I'd like to invite
Karthik Ramamurthy, who
is director of product
management from Dell EMC,
to talk about our
partnership and tiering
to Google Cloud Storage.
KARTHIK RAMAMURTHY: So for
folks who don't know me,
my name is Karthik Ramamurthy.
And I'm part of the product
management team for Isilon,
which is part of the
Dell business unit.
So Isilon, we started as a
company back in 2000, 2001,
with a focus on trying to
build out a scalable NAS
platform to serve the needs
of some specific verticals,
specifically to life sciences,
to media entertainment,
specifically customers who
need a lot of unstructured data
and a lot of highly throughput
and highly scalable data.
Over time, the company
has grown as part of EMC
and now part of Dell.
We've got over 8,000
plus enterprise
customers using Isilon.
What makes Isilon unique
to all of these customers
and why they continue to
invest and buy more of Isilon
is because it's a platform
that's highly simple to manage,
it's extremely scalable.
We've got all of the
enterprise-grade capabilities
that customers expect
on a platform and all
of the enterprise-grade
security elements to it,
everything from FCC compliance
to typical security tools.
So all of the capabilities
that a customer requires
on the enterprise is now all
available for [INAUDIBLE]
and NAS platforms as well.
What makes all of this
very interesting to a lot
of customers is
the fact that you
have that same level
of efficiency and skill
as the amount of
data starts to grow.
And from [AUDIO OUT]
manage the data today,
you know that the largest part
of your data that's growing
is your unstructured data, which
is roughly growing at about,
as market says, roughly
about three times
of the rest of the enterprise.
And so being able to
have a single user
experience for
your data, which is
both structured
and unstructured,
is what customers look for.
And that's where we, from
a business perspective
and from a Isilon
perspective, approach
the build that we do,
which is give customers
the exact same experience,
whether they are running
the data on the edge clusters,
the data within a
core data center,
or whether they're
running it in the cloud.
And now, what makes
a cloud interesting
is customers look at Cloud
both from a data mobility
perspective and from a
flexibility perspective,
but also looking for ways to
be able to offer lower cost
storage for some of their warm
or hot and potentially even
cold data, all right?
So from an EMC perspective
and from a Dell perspective,
we've got our own solutions.
We've got a product called
Elastic Cloud storage, which
allows customers to
move data between Isilon
and then on-prem storage.
Now, what makes on-prem
storage interesting
is it gives
customers the ability
to access the data within
the same protocol timeouts,
within the same expected
reliability and response
times from that cluster.
Now, what that means is, when
we started looking at, OK,
we've got an on-prem solution
in the form of Isilon.
We've got an object platform,
which is also on-prem.
Customers are looking
for off-prem solutions.
Customers are looking for
public cloud solutions.
And so we started to look
at a number of cloud targets
that we can support.
And a key element to supporting
different cloud targets
is, can we have a
cloud target that
enables customers to get
the dollar per terabyte
that they need
for their storage?
And also, can they get
the predictable SLAs
and the predictable latencies
in terms of access to that data.
And that brings us to
partnering with Google,
obviously as a very
important partner for us,
is enabling customers to start
to tier all of their cold data
from the Isilon onto a
Google Cloud Storage target.
So customers today
using Isilon can
put their performance data,
their high throughput data,
on a local on-prem
Isilon cluster.
But as the data starts to
age and the data gets cool,
you can start to move it off to
a Google Cloud Storage target
and still be able to access
it within the same namespace
that they would with
the data on-prem.
What that gives
customers is essentially
a seamless experience, right?
Whether the data is
on-prem, whether the data is
on a different tier of
storage within the cluster,
or whether the data get steered
off to a Google Cloud Storage
target, you get
the same experience
from a cluster perspective.
You have the same
security credentials.
enterprise features.
It's largely
agnostic and largely
transparent to the customer,
whether the data is on-prem
or whether that's in the Cloud.
And that's important for a lot
of the enterprise customers--
and I'm sure a lot of people
can relate to that as well--
is your end customers
and end users
essentially are
going to say, here's
what I need from a
storage perspective,
here's the expected SLAs, and
here's the expected performance
characteristics that I
expect from my storage.
You, storage vendor,
go figure out
how do you provide that to me.
And for us being able
to do that with a vendor
like Google enables
customers to make
that choice of whether they
want to keep that data on-prem
or in the cloud, but essentially
keep it seamless for them.
[APPLAUSE]
KIRILL TROPIN: So we've talked
about tiering data from on-prem
to Coldline and to Nearline.
Turns out that
many customers want
to tier the data from hot
storage to cold storage
as well.
So before we go
into tiering, I'd
like to remind you all
of the storage classes
that we have in Google
Cloud Storage today.
So we have four of them.
It's Multi-regional, Regional,
Nearline, and Coldline.
So two left ones,
Multi-regional and Regional,
are hot storage classes.
Multi-regional is geo redundant
across two or more regions
that are 100 miles apart.
And then Regional is
designed for hot data
stored within a single region.
And Multi-regional is typically
used for content storage
and delivery.
And Regional is typically
for big data analytics
within a given region.
Then we also have two storage
classes for cool data.
That's Nearline for
infrequently accessed data.
And we also have
Coldline storage class.
That's for data that's
accessed less than once
a year that's typically
archive and very cold data.
And across all of them we have
the same durability, 11 9's.
We have the same
instant access speed.
We have the same API
across all of them.
One interesting feature
that we shipped last year
was Object Level storage
class and data lifecycle
across those storage classes.
So we see many customers
wanting to use multiple storage
classes at the same time
and age out their data
from hot storage to cold
storage over time and pay
less over time.
And we've seen customers copy
the data from hot storage
to cold storage and when
they decide they need to use
or they will copy it back.
And there was quite
inefficient for customers
so we wanted to make it
very simple for them.
And simplify that they don't
need to worry about that.
So we've created Per
Object storage class.
With Per Object storage class,
you can keep your bucket,
you can keep your
name of your objects,
and you just change settings
on a given object and say,
now this object is Nearline or
now this object is Coldline.
But everything stayed the same.
So objects stayed in place,
is the same object name,
the same bucket name,
the same API call.
So if your application
was using that object,
it wouldn't notice any
change and everything
will keep working as intended.
And we also ship data lifecycle
across storage classes.
You can create a simple
policy that will say,
if my objects are older than 30
days, or some number of days,
move them to Nearline.
As we see, a lot of
customers use their data
very frequently
within first 30 days,
but then they no longer use
the data after those 30 days.
And typically, they would
move the data to Nearline.
And after a longer
period of time,
they'll move it to Coldline
as they don't expect
to use the data much longer.
So what's cool about
this project storage
class and our consistent API
across those storage classes,
once data ends up
in Coldline, you
don't need to worry about
restoring it back or copying it
somewhere.
You can keep accessing
against the same API,
against the same object name.
And that provides a
very simple solution
for our customers that your data
between hot and cold storage.
I like to compare us
to S3, because there
are quite a few areas
where we are winning.
So starting from the far right
is Multi-regional storage.
And our competitor does not
have really direct competition
in that area.
So you could create
the S3 standard
with cross-regional application.
And you would need to pay
for two regional copies.
And you would need
to pay for network
to replicate across those
two regional copies.
And that adds up to much
higher number of like 4.2 just
for storage--
4.2 cents per gigabyte month--
plus network to replicate
across the regions.
And with us, we have a
much simpler solution
with Multi-regional storage.
You just create one bucket, and
we'll take care of everything
for you.
You don't need to
pay for second copy,
you don't need to pay for
network to replicate it,
you don't need to worry
about failing over
between those two regions
if one of them goes down.
We'll take care of
all of that for you.
And because of probably
that simply API,
all of our storage classes
have exactly the same API
and exactly the
same performance.
You don't need to configure
anything extra outside
of those storage classes.
So then if we move to
Regional storage, that's
for hot data access
within the region,
we have a quite
comparable product.
It's GCS Regional
versus S3 standard.
And we are slightly cheaper
than our competition
around the world.
And then going to
infrequent accessed data,
we have GCS Nearline, which is
at $0.01 per gigabyte month.
And our competition
charges 1.25 cents
per gigabyte month-- so
again, slightly cheaper there.
And then going to cold
storage, so we have product
that's called GCS Coldline.
We launched it five months ago.
And with Coldline,
we have the same API
and the same latency
characteristics
as any other storage classes.
And that means
customers don't need
to worry about
integrating with it
or treating it differently
like anything else.
And there is no direct
competition in that space.
So when customers
think about storage
and comparing it to
Amazon S3, usually they
think it's apples-to-apples
comparison between Google Cloud
Storage, or GCS, and S3.
But turns out,
with a S3, you need
to add a lot of different
layers to compare
to what GCS provides.
So if you want to use
a really cold storage,
you need to add Glacier,
you need to figure out
to integrate with it.
You need to restore
data out of Glacier
before it becomes usable.
If you want to have
Multi-regional storage,
or geo redundant
storage, you need
to use CRR, which is
an extra API for you
can figure those regions
and failover between them.
If you want to use
high throughput network
or if you want to get high
throughput for your data,
you need to use
Accelerated Transfer.
And they charge extra for that.
With us, we don't
charge anything extra.
All of your data is
accelerated out-of-the box,
because we use fantastic Google
network to transfer your data.
And then, if you
want to use CDN,
you need to include the
CloudFront with Amazon.
With us, edge caching
is part of the product.
And as you've seen
from Artur, we
have fantastic latency
because of that,
because we have so many
different tiers of cache
and it's part of
the core product
that you don't need
to pay anything extra.
You don't need to configure
anything on top of that.
It is part of our simple
Google Cloud Storage.
To summarize, we have
a large portfolio
that covers many
different use cases.
So we have Multi-regional
storage class
that's perfect for content
storage and delivery.
We have Regional
storage class that's
perfect for big data analytics.
We have Nearline for
infrequently accessed data.
And we have Coldline
for cold data.
All of the storage
classes are united
by the same API, the same online
latency, the same network,
the same tiering that
we have at Google.
Now, we have lifecycle
across those stories classes
that you don't need to worry
about configuring or copying
any data between
those storage classes
and then changing your API.
Everything is very
smooth for you right now.
And we also have lots of
different partnerships
that help you
integrate and help you
use Google Cloud Storage in any
scenario that you might have.
So you can learn more
about Google Cloud Storage
at cloud.google.com/storage.
And you might have heard
that this morning we've
announced a much larger
free trial with Google Cloud
Platform.
And we also announced Free Tier,
which includes Google Cloud
Storage now.
So everyone has access to free
five gigabytes in the United
States.
And it doesn't expire.
There is no limit on it.
So it's Free Tier.
Feel free to use it and feel
free to try out Google Cloud
Storage.
So we have quite some time left.
So maybe a few
questions, if there any
questions in the audience.
So we had three guest speakers.
So all of us can
answer your questions.
And I was asked, if
you have any questions,
please stand up and
walk to the mic.
It's because we are
recording, so that we'll
hear a question in
the recording as well.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]